[Applaus]
[Musik]
neben mathe füchse heute reden wir über
koalitions mathematik das ist eine ganz
besondere mathematik deren regeln nur
gelten wenn gerade
koalitionsverhandlungen sind
ich bin leider ganz schlechtem rechnet
ja super schlecht rechnen ist quasi
voraussetzung für
koalitionsverhandlungen
textaufgaben 1 christian lindner
verspricht den bürgern 30 milliarden
steuersenkungen plus milliardenschwere
investitionen plus weiterhin die
schwarze null
frage wie doof ist ein christian lindner
12 sehr gut oliver verdammte inklusion
eigentlich weiß der lindner genau dass
das nicht geht da hat ja keine
rechenschwäche hier das ist
rechenschwäche eins und eins ist eins
und nicht reif
na gut er hatte keinen taschenrechner
dabei so angeblich hat jamaika 30
milliarden zu verteilen ohne neue
schulden zu machen
die versprechungen die uns die vier
parteien machen kosten aber bis zu 178
milliarden fällt immer auf
ich weiß es die eine zahl ist viel mehr
richtig gut sagt ja und dabei gelingt
jamaika ein echtes matte kunst stück
selbst in diesen 178 milliarden sack
voller versprechungen ist keine einzige
maßnahme die zum beispiel kinderarmut
bekämpft muss man erst mal hinkriegen
aktuelle studie
21 prozent der kinder in deutschland
leben dauerhaft oder wiederkehrend in
armut diese kinder haben nichts von all
dem jamaica ideen kindergelderhöhungen
freibeträge es geht alles nur
mittelstandsfamilien ja aber frau
schneider in wirklichkeit haben die
jamaikaner eben auch nur 30 milliarden
zu verschenken
erstens die verschenkten gar nichts das
ist unser geld und zweitens und jetzt
werden sehr viele fdp-wähler vor schreck
vom polo fiat fallen
wie wär's denn wenn wir endlich mal den
verdammten spitzensteuersatz erhöht ja
warum denn nicht von jetzt 42 auf sagen
wir mal 48 gut und dann gilt natürlich
erst ab einem viel höheren einkommen
damit die sauereien der kalten
progression endlich aufhört und
normalverdiener entlastet werden kalte
progression sabine verstanden genau wie
geteilt das ist im grunde ganz einfach
ja ich erkläre es jetzt mal für dich die
entsteht die kalte progression wenn der
arbeitnehmer in eine höhere steuerklasse
rutscht und dann wir fragen mal eine der
führenden physikerinnen des landes dann
gehört dazu damit die progression nicht
steiler wird erst einmal um auch eine
verschiebung um um den betrag der
grundfreibetrags so also wenn ich die
pampe freibetrag von 100 euro senke dann
also der steigt entscheiden
ich habe es jetzt auch nicht verstanden
möchte experte schneider weiter und
höher
[Applaus]